russia's defense ministry says these are
some of its troops which had been
positioned on the border with ukraine
they're returning to base after
finishing training exercises
as the training comes to an end the
troops as usual will march back to their
home stations units from the southern
and western military districts that
completed their tasks already have
started loading on trains and motor
vehicles they will start moving to their
home bases individual units will march
on their own in military columns
while this raises hopes that tensions
could ease between russia and ukraine
there are still large-scale military
exercises taking place
and it's not clear how many units are
being pulled back
news of the troops drawdown came just as
the german chancellor olaf schultz
arrived in russia for talks with
president vladimir putin who said war
was the last thing he wanted
do we want war or not of course we don't
and it's for that reason that we have
submitted a proposal as to a negotiation
process as a result of which there
should be a guarantee for security for
everybody including our country
chancellor olaf schultz said some
aspects of russia's demands on ukraine
were worth considering while stressing
the need for diplomacy to succeed the
diplomatism
today i fully agree that diplomatic
efforts have yet to be exhausted
we have to find a peaceful resolution to
this crisis
several troops have been pulled back
which is a good sign and we hope that
this will continue in the belgian
capital nato secretary general jen
stoltenberg expressed cautious optimism
at the news of the russian drawdown
there are signs from moscow that
diplomacy should continue
this gives
grounds for cautious optimism
but so far
we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground despite
these intense diplomatic efforts there
are still many outstanding issues at the
heart of the crisis
vladimir putin says he is ready to talk
to u.s leaders about ukraine's request
to join the 30-member nato alliance and
he says that is a conversation which
cannot be put off any longer something
both nato and u.s leaders have refused
to discuss so far
and until that issue is resolved it is
now clear that this crisis could
continue for months to come
dorsal jabari al jazeera moscow